Transcriber: Maram S
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ، السلام
عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته .
اليوم طبعًا معروف أن
قطاع النفط و الغاز يمثل تقريبًا
٥٣٪ من خليط الطاقة العالمي .
الذي يستخدم بشكل رئيسي
لدعم الاقتصاد العالمي
والارتقاء بمستوى المعيشة للإنسان
على كوكب الأرض في جميع النطاقات طبعًا .
وكذلك الحد من الكثير من المشاكل .
التي يواجهها سواء كانت البطالة أو
سواء كانت في مؤشر فقر الطاقة .
والتساؤل الكبير الذي يدور
طبعًا ليس فقط في الدول البتروليه
مثل المملكة السعودية ،
ولكن حتى الدول الغير بترولية .
الصناعية التي تستهلك النفط والغاز .
هل سيستمر هذا القطاع في هذا
الدور الرئيسي على المدى البعيد
في ظل التحديات البيئية
الكبيرة التي يواجهها ؟
والحملات الاعلامية الكبيرة
التي تنادي بانتهاء عصر النفط الذهبي .
من خلال ربطه اللامنطقي
بالكثير من الكوارث البيئية
مثل الاحتباس الحراري والتغير المناخي
وبعض الكوارث البيئية التي تحدث
في العالم بين الحين والآخر .
حقيقة أن هذه التساؤلات
الكثيرة كانت في مخيلتي نهاية عام ٢٠١٨
عندما تم اختياري رئيسًا
لجمعية مهندسي البترول العالمية .
كنت وقتها طبعًا لم يكن لدي أدنى
شك بأن هذه الصناعة القوية التاريخية
بمقدورها التحول السريع إلى
صناعة منخفضة الانبعاثات
من خلال الحد الكبير
من عملية حرق غاز الميثان
المصاحب للنفط.
ومن خلال أيضا التقنيات
الجديدة التي تستطيع وبشكل كبير
الحد من انبعاثات غاز ثاني اكسيد الكربون
الذي يصدر عن طريق عملية
حرق المنتجات البترولية تساؤلات
تساؤلات كثيرة كانت أيضا
في مخيلتي كيف تستطيع
جمعية مهندسي البترول العالمية
بتاريخها الطويل الذي يمتد
إلى سبعين سنة تقريبًا.
والثروة المعلوماتية الضخمة التي
جمعتها خلال تلك الفتره
والتوسع الجغرافي الكبير لوجود فروع
لها في مئة وثلاثين دولة حول العالم .
وقربها من مراكز الأبحاث والجامعات
مثل جامعة الملك فهد للبترول والمعادن
لوجود فروع لها في ثلاثمئة وأربعين
جامعة حول العالم .
كيف تستطيع هذه الجمعية بهذه
القوة والتاريخ والبنية التحتية
مساعدة قطاع النفط والغاز للتحول
إلى صناعة منخفضة الانبعاثات
والتسريع من هذا التحول.
كان علينا طبعًا عمل بحث
لدراسة تأثير هذه الحملات
المضللة بعض الشيء.
وجدنا أن التأثير كبير جدًا
خاصة على فئة الشباب .
وجدنا مثلا أن عدد طلبة هندسة البترول في
الجامعات الأوروبية والأمريكية بالأخص
انخفاض حاد خلال خمس سنوات الماضية ، وجدنا
أن بعض الشركات البترولية العالمية تواجه
صعوبة كبيرة في جذب المواهب الشابة من
خريجي الجامعات إلى درجة.
أن أحد الشركات الكبرى غيرت اسمها
لوجود لفظ نفط في اسمها
لتمكينها من جذب المواهب الشابة من
خريجين الجامعات في تلك الدولة.
وجدنا أيضًا أن بعض الشركات
الكبرى تواجه صعوبة
في الحصول على تراخيص وعلى قروض
بنكية تساعدها لتطوير
حقولها النفطية والغازية .
كان لا بد من تطوير استراتيجية
شاملة تساعد قطاع النفط
وتسرع عملية التحول الذي ذكرتها قبل قليل
كان لا بد لنا من إعادة مفهوم
Energy Transition
أو مفهوم تحول الطاقة من معناه
وتعريفه التقليدي الذي
اليوم يطالب بانتهاء عصر النفط
إلى تعريف شامل يشمل جميع مصادر الطاقة
ويطالب جميع مصادر
الطاقة بما فيها النفط والغاز
التحول إلى مصادر منخفضة الانبعاثات
مع وجود هدف أعلى بحلول عام ٢٠٥٠
الوصول إلى معدلات صفر من صافي الانبعاثات .
كان لا بد علينا أيضا
من طرح معادلة لمشاريع الطاقة
معادلة جديدة متزنة .
مشاريع الطاقة في الماضي كان ينظر لها إما
من جانب اقتصادي بحت أو جانب بيئي بحت .
طرحنا بعد آخر، بعد ثالث،
الا و هو الأهداف التنموية المستدامة .
تأثير هذه المشاريع على
مستوى معيشة الإنسان .
الحلول الكثيرة لمشاكلها الاجتماعية
مثل البطالة ومثل فقر الطاقة.
كان علينا التوجه إلى
الجامعات بحكم قربنا من الجامعات
إلى مراكز الأبحاث لتحفيز
طرح مبادرات جديدة
لتطوير تقنيات جديدة
تحد من هذه الانبعاثات .
كان علينا، وهذا مهم جدًا
التواصل مع الهيئات الدولية البيئية
الحكومية وغير الحكومية مثل وكالة
الطاقة الدولية ومنظمة أوبك وغيرها
لشرح هذا الفكر الجديد
وهذا التحول الجديد وهذه المعادلة المتزنة
لمشاريع الطاقة.
كان علينا أيضا تكثيف
المؤتمرات الدولية التي تنظمها الجمعية
والمشاركة الفعالة في المؤتمرات
التي تنظمها ايضًا الجمعيات الاخرى
لإبراز ما اقمت به وتقوم به
صناعة النفط و الغاز العالمية الآن،
لإبراز ما قامت به وتقوم به
صناعة النفط والغاز العالمية الآن
وفي المستقبل للحد من هذه الانبعاثات .
وهي كثيرة أذكر منها،
ثورة الغاز الصخري والنجاح
الباهر في الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
لهذه التقنية الجديدة التي حدت بشكل
كبير من انبعاثات غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون
لاستخدام هذا الغاز في توليد
الكهرباء بدلا من الفحم الحجري .
استثمارات مليارية قامت بها الصناعة
لتطوير تقنيات جديدة غير موجودة حاليًا
أذكر مثال منها مبادرة
النفط و الغاز البيئية
او مايطلق عليها
Oil and Gas Climate Initiative OGCI
استثمار مليار دولار, تصوروا
مليار دولار خلال عشر سنوات .
سوف تستثمر لتطوير تقنيات جديدة
تحدمن انبعاثات غاز الميثان
وغاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون
واخيًرا وليس اخرًا،
القطاع المستقبلي  الذي اتمنى
أن أرى استثمارات كثيرة فيه وزخم كبير فيه
خاصة في الجامعات ، هو قطاع
تحويل النفط إلى مواد كيميائية
غير قابلة للاحتراق ذات قيمة مضافة
عالية تساعد على رفع مستوى معيشة
الإنسان على وجه الأرض
وتحد من الانبعاثات الغازية .
حاليا معروف أن ٢٠٪ إلى ٢٥٪
من البرميل يتحول إلى مواد كيمائية
غير قابلة للاحتراق ، والبقية يكرر
وينتج منه وقود البنزين والديزل
وهذا كما نعرف يحرق ويصدر
عنه غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون .
هذا القطاع الجديد الذي يحتاج الى كميات
هائلة من البحث والتطوير سيرفع هذه النسبة
من ٢٠٪ الى ٤٠٪ ولربما
٥٠٪ في العشرين سنة القادمة .
سيؤدي إلى خفض كبير من الانبعاثات
وإنتاج مواد جديدة قد يعني
تطور استخدامات جديدة
للنفط تساعد على الحفاظ على الطلب
العالمي للنفط على مدى المدى البعيد
والأهم من ذلك امتصاص الفائض من النفط
إذا ما شهدنا ارتفاعات
غير مسبوقة في السيارات الكهربائية.
الرحلة طويلة رحلة مملوءة بالتحديات
ولكنها شيقة في نفس الوقت
والدول والشركات
البترولية تتفاوت في هذه الرحلة.
هناك دول متقدمة ومنها
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
وكذلك المملكة العربية السعودية
التي بدأت هذه الرحلة
قبل خمسين سنة عندما تم
إنشاء شبكة الغاز الوطنية
التي حدت بشكل كبير من عملية حرق
غاز الميثان واستخدمته هو
والغاز الغير مصاحب
لدعم الصناعة البتروكيميائية
وتحلية المياه وتوليد الكهرباء
وصناعة الأسمدة في المملكة العربية السعودية
والذي حد بشكل كبير من انبعاثات
غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون وغاز الميثان
للمملكة العربية السعودية، والمملكة أيضًا
أطلقت مبادرات لرفع كفاءة الطاقة في
المملكة العربية السعودية،
وإنجازات كبيرة لهذه المبادرة
ليس فقط لرفع كفاءة
كفاءة الطاقة الكهربائية
ولكن أيضا حدت بشكل كبير
من الهدر الذي كان موجود في
استهلاك الوقود مثل البنزين والديزل .
كذلك المشاريع التي نسمعها بين الحين والآخر
لتوليد الكهرباء عن طريق الطاقة البديلة .
مشروع سدير و دومة الجندل وغيرها
كجزء من رؤية المملكة
٢٠٣٠ للوصول إلى
٥٠٪ من استهلاك المملكة للكهرباء
سيتم توليده عن طريق الطاقة
البديلة بحلول عام ٢٠٣٠
وهذا بذاته سيحد بشكل
كبير من عملية انبعاثات
غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون .
مبادرة اقتصاد الكربون
الدائري التي طرحته المملكة
إلى مجموعة العشرين وتمت
تبنيه من قبل قادة المجموعة العشرين
هذه المبادرة التي ليس فقط
ستحل مشاكل الكربون ،
ولكنها تحول هذا التحدي البيئي الكبير
إلى فرص استثمارية
واعدة ، وستنتج مواد جديدة
من الكربون تدعم ليس فقط الاقتصاد
السعودي ولكن الاقتصاد العالمي .
وأخيرًا وليس آخرًا،
المبادرة التي طرحها ولي
العهد حفظه الله المملكة الخضراء
لزراعة خمسين مليار شجرة في المنطقة
سيؤدي ذلك ليس فقط لتلطيف الجو
، ولكن يمتص كميات هائلة
من غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون ،
وسيعجل في رحلة تحول
قطاع الطاقة السعودي
للوصول إلى الاهداف المذكورة
وبهذه المناسبة طبعا نريد أن نهنئ الوطن
بقرب احتفالات اليوم
الوطني الواحد و التسعين.
نهنئ الوطن وندعو له بالاستقرار
والازدهار إن شاء الله .
الحقيقة أن هذا الزخم الكبير
في صناعة النفط والغاز للتحول
إلى مصادر طاقة منخفضة الانبعاثات،
وهذه الجهود الجبارة وهذه
الاستثمارات الكبيرة تجعلني أنا شخصيا
متفائل للمستقبل، العالم شغوف
للطاقة كما ونوعا ،
ويحتاج إلى كميات هائلة .
من الطاقة نوعا وكما دعمًا
للاقتصاد العالمي الذي يجب أن ينمو ،
ودعما للأهداف التنموية المستدامة،
ومنها الأهداف السبعة عشر التي
طرحته منظمة الأمم المتحدة
قبل ٥ او ٦ سنوات .
أحد هذه الأهداف هدف
يتعلق بمؤشر فقر الطاقة،
اليوم حسب سجلات الأمم المتحدة .
يوجد مليار شخص في العالم تحت خط فقر الطاقة
ليس لديهم كهرباء وليس لديهم وقود الطبخ
يستخدمون الكتلة الحيوية ، الحطب
والأشجار في عملية الطبخ مما يعرضهم
إلى أمراض كثيرة .
كذلك أن التعداد السكاني العالم في تزايد .
من المتوقع أن عدد سكان العالم يزيد بمعدل
مليار إنسان في العشرين سنة القادمة .
والكثير من هؤلاء سيولدون
في دول فقيرة خاصة في افريقيا.
فالعالم في شغف كبير للطاقة،
لدعم اقتصاده ودعم
الأهداف التنموية المستدامة
المذكورة في تقرير الأمم المتحدة
وأيضا الغير مذكورة لذلك نظرتنا
المستقبلية متفائلة .
العالم سيحتاج الى خليط من الطاقة حسب رأيي.
سيكون النفط والغاز في مقدمتها .
ولكن النفط والغاز سيكونان أكثر كفاءة
وأقل انخفاضا للانبعاثات .
سنرى استخدامات جديدة للنفط والغاز
طبعا مدعومًا أو متممًا
بمصادر الطاقة المتجددة
ومصادر الطاقة الأخرى ومن ضمنها الهيدروجين
وأتمنى أن يكون الهيدروجين
الأزرق لكي يكون مصدره من النفط والغاز
لدعم الاقتصاد ودعم
الاهداف التنموية المستدامة للعالم.
يبقى سؤال أخير .
هل يكفي ما تقوم به صناعة
النفط والغاز العالمية اليوم
للحفاظ على كوكب الأرض من
هذه الخاطر و الكوارث البيئية؟
جوابي لا، لا يكفي قطاع
النفط والغاز اليوم مسؤول عن
ثلث هذه الانبعاثات .
هناك قطاعات أخرى مسؤولة
أيضا عن هذه الانبعاثات الغازية .
وأذكر مثال واحد،
Deforstation أو قطع أشجار
الغابات الاستوائية وتقليص الغلاف
الأخضر لكوكب الأرض .
لو نظرنا لهذا القطاع كدولة ،
لاصبح ترتيبه الثالث عالميا
في صافي انبعاثات غاز ثاني
أكسيد الكربون المكافئ .
فالمسؤولية كبيرة والمسؤولية على الجميع
يجب على الجميع وعلى جميع القطاعات تحمل
مسؤوليتهم التاريخية ومسؤوليتهم الأخلاقية
للحفاظ على كوكب الأرض .
والأهم من ذلك الحفاظ على الإنسان
الذي خلقه الله سبحانه وتعالى عبادته ومن ثم
لتعمير هذا الكوكب .
السلام عليكم .